that was Joan Baez performing after her  induction into the Rock and Roll Hall of  Fame last night for more than 50 years  she's been an icon of the folk music  movement and a global activist just  before the ceremony we spoke to her  about the honor how does it feel to be  in the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame a  little bit silly but really nice yeah  silly part well that did I make a little  bit fish-out-of-water but not in the  early 1960s as the folk revival took  root Joan Baez emerged as its most  prominent female voice  she'd use her influence to introduce  another young musician to the world  recording Bob Dylan songs and inviting  him to join